welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of the
trailer for Ahsoka the new Star Wars
series coming this August following
versus Dustin as the former Jedi Ahsoka
Tano from her brief appearances on the
Mandalorian but really extending the
lore from the animated Star Wars Rebels
series before that Clone Wars I'm gonna
break down this trailer frame by frame
for the Star Wars Easter eggs who all
these characters are the timelines some
really cool visual details first clip
something's coming
something dark
foreign
[Music]
you know this badass walks among what
appeared to be the ruins of a Jedi
Temple one of the older ones it's got a
series of columns all broken at the top
and Black Sands cast over a stone tile
floor the framing of Ahsoka alone
walking up this immense walkway recalls
the imagery of her leaving the Jedi
Order in Clone Wars season 5 which she
was framed for bombing the Jedi Temple
on Coruscant and the ensuant persecution
left such a bad taste in her mouth that
she had to part ways with her longtime
mentor and a kid Skywalker which made it
really interesting when she returned to
chapter 13 the Mandalorian an episode
interestingly titled the Jedi when she
wasn't supposed to be a Jedi anymore but
somewhere deep down she's always been a
Jedi at heart so is this the ruins of a
Jedi Temple well there are some markings
on all these ruins that do look vaguely
similar to The Underground Jedi Temple
on loath ball in Rebels and so we could
look at the parallelism here as a bit of
a Jedi homecoming for Ahsoka or is it
because notice ahead of her is a massive
statue that we do not see that top of or
that base of structurally it's similar
to the massive crumbling Jedi statues
surrounding the jedha plateau in Rogue
one but later in the trailer as Ahsoka
duels Morgan ellsmith's corvus droids
from chapter 13. in this same setting
you can see another smaller broken
statue with bare feet which as a huge
fan of lost gives me some major Vibes of
the broken four-toed statue foot of
Tourette so could this actually be a
Sith Temple chapter 14 the Mandalorian
took grogu to the Jedi Temple ruins on
python a planet in the Deep core
actually let's pull up the galactic star
map here because maps are gonna play a
very very big role on this series it's
all about Maps if there's some places
you gotta go I'm the one you need to
know it's the map so the Deep core
region of the galactic star map was
actually brought up in chapter 19 the
Mandalorian when DR pershing's Wikipedia
article about corsant which gets cut off
right before mentioning the planet
that's closest in center of the Galaxy
which according to the map is bis
b-y-s-s you know as an abyss Aaron
always subtle with a wordplay here biss
was considered Palpatine Throne world
it's actually more from Legends so it
remains a mystery how canonical titles
will use it but it is very very close to
tython and here Ahsoka mentioned
something's coming something dark which
could be her investigating the darkness
creeping up on grogu and on the new
Republic in the form of Palpatine's
Shadow operation the first order but
perhaps by this time Palpatine would
have moved from this to hexagall where
we see him at the beginning of the rise
of Skywalker when the Sith Eternal has
successfully cloned him these ruins are
the same location that we see later in
the trailer when Ahsoka faces balin's
skull when projected around these ruins
are a blue star map the same
configuration that surrounds the Ahsoka
title card of this series so this place
could contain an old Jedi or old Sith
star map of the unknown regions where
the Pergo hyperspace whales took thrawn
and Ezra Bridger in Rebels because that
has been ahsoka's mission to try to find
Ezra we saw some Pergo cameoine in
chapter 17 the Mandalorian the recent
season premiere and Bale Organa hinted
at them and Obi-Wan Kenobi and it has
all been leading to this now some people
say this Starry location looks like the
world World Between Worlds and Rebels
that's an interdimensional realm that
can kind of see through time that Ezra
was guided through by loath wolves and
he used it to save Ahsoka by pulling her
in but she was forced to re-enter the
point in her timeline after Vader left
so she didn't really get trapped there
time travel was pretty limited hopefully
stays that way but I'm telling you Star
Wars Rebels crazy show you have to watch
it I just don't think here this will be
the world Between Worlds I thought it
was really fun to explore in the
animated show in live action it's just
gonna open up too many questions of time
travel but I love this move Ahsoka
ignites her lightsabers and does this
spinny move to cut a hole that drops her
to the chamber below she did this same
maneuver in the Clone Wars final episode
to help her and Rex escape the clone
troopers during order 66. let's move on
this is a new beginning
for some
War
for others
okay we see a red lucasfilm logo a
switch from the normal green lucasrome
logo another transition from the heroic
green of Star Wars to the morally
compromised red Natasha leopardizo plays
Sabine Wren from Star Wars Rebels
another Mandalorian character from house
wren who previously was a Weapon
Specialist for the Empire but defected
mostly known for very very short hair
now her hair has grown the hell out so
we can see those vibrant colors really
shining interesting how she is kneeling
before her Mandalorian helmet as if she
is praying to
interesting parallel there with how
dogmatic the children of the watch are
with their Mandalorian iconography but
it also just feels like she's wrestling
with her Mandalorian ancestry as she
always is she never got along with her
mother Ursa ran on Cronus since she
defied the Empire that was like an
embarrassment to her family but she is a
character who rightfully won the
darksaber from gar Saxon in that arc on
Rebels it was none of that Elder one
possession logic that we saw
this week on the Mandalorian but we also
have Sabine to blame for just giving the
darksaber to bogoton and cursing
Mandalore instead of it on this stupid
path we see she has the most cat these
cats are from Ezra's Homeworld of lothal
and we hear the voice of Balin saying
this is a new beginning for some Ward
for others power Ray Stevenson plays
this villainous character Balin skull
who seems to have an apprentice Shin
hutti played by Ivana sakno skull and
hati are the names of the two wolves
that chase the Sun and the Moon in Norse
mythology this wolf reference could
align with the loath Wolves of lothal
and the son of the Moon might align with
the sun in the daughter of mortis in
Jedi force mythology from the Clone Wars
mortis Arc and those deities were also
depicted on the lothal Jedi Temple in
Rebels Ahsoka back in the ruins fights
with these red droids with the Spears
and again these are these same ones that
Morgan ellsmith used on corvus so these
are the forces of el Smith and by
extension the forces of drawn and based
on the hole in the ground this is right
after Ahsoka comes back out of the hole
we see heres and Doula captain of the
ghost in Star Wars Rebels now played by
Mary Elizabeth Winstead she's a Twilight
pilot one of the best pilots in the
Rebel Alliance and the ship she's pilot
in here is not the ghost it's really a
smaller Detachment from the ghost called
The Phantom and the jacket she wears
bears a symbol of the crew of The Ghost
and with zeb's Cameo recently on the
Mandalorian it looks like we might see a
live-action reunion of the entire crew
of the ghost which would be awesome the
Astromech we see here is Chopper that's
a little sticker from Rebels who cameo'd
on the base in Rogue one and I always
pissed off Rebels fans by reminding
everyone that this guy killed hundreds
of thousands of Imperials by sabotaging
a star destroyer and he pushes droids to
their deaths for no reason Shin storms a
bridge of a new Republic vessel the
badge of the captain is a single dot
which means Lieutenant Shin's hooded
appearance reminds us of Luke Skywalker
when he stormed mop Gideon's light
Cruiser in the Mandalorian season 2
finale but Shin's motives are far more
hostile what if she has a braid the kind
Jedi padawans wear and started a really
unfortunate Trend in the early odds so
Bailey and shin might not be Sith and
Apprentice but a kind of perversion of
the Jedi Order their Sabers are not
quite red from cracked kyber crystals
that they would have had to bleed their
rage into they're more of an orange
color is it not all the way there now if
you're the kind of person who watches a
fantasy movie named dungeons the
dragon's honor among Thieves and leaves
the theater going I need more fantasy
action then you are going to want to get
Dragonair silent Gods the second it
drops Dragonair silent Gods is an
upcoming PC and mobile open world High
fantasy RPG Dragonair silent God has
collaborated with Dungeons and Dragons
meaning that iconic gameplay features
and characters that you already know
from DND are Incorporated right into the
game Now spoiler alert one of those
characters is Drizzt dorton the
absolutely most badass drove from Dragon
lands so you know sign me up the open
world and stick Graphics of Dragonair
silent Gods gives me the feel of play in
a tabletop RPG without having to devote
a ton of space in your apartment to
Miniatures and Battlefield set pieces
but if you also do that no no shame and
hey if you're only exposure to D is
honor among Thieves you'll still find
plenty recognize including Dragonborn
bards mimic chests basically everything
but Hugh Grant's undeniable charm so
that sounds cool to you then you can
click the link in the description below
to pre-register for Dragonair silent
Gods to get a special in-game gift if
you can't wait keep an eye out for the
new teaser on IGN or join the Discord
server via the link below the fold
Dragonair silent Gods is waiting for you
okay on to the next clip
things have changed
whoa so the music of this trailer is
incredible Furious violin strings we see
some familiar imagery here for Rebels
fans ahsoka's T6 shuttle and Ahsoka
reunites with Sabine Wren on lothal the
same Doc in the communication Tower the
same place where they teamed up in the
rebels epilogue to go search for Ezra in
last year's Star Wars celebration
footage which I was lucky enough to see
unlike this year's because it's in
London we do in the scene actually see a
live-action version of that same mural
of the entire ghost crew and it has the
same 2D animated look that we see in the
animated show so it sounds like that
initial search for Ezra was unsuccessful
but they're gonna give it another go now
that Ahsoka has made some progress
finding thrawn and I like how sabine's
flight jacket has her Phoenix Squadron
patch on the sleeve there we see three
new Republic Freighters blasting in from
hyperspace these look like the gr-75
medium transports like what we saw
departing Hoth and The Empire Strikes
Back and inside we see one of the
cleanest looking Hollow calls I've ever
seen in Star Wars with mon mothma
Genevieve O'Reilly who first played a
younger version of mon Mothman and the
deleted scene Revenge of the Sith came
back to player in Rogue one and recently
played her in Andor during the Imperial
era after Return of the Jedi now as
Chancellor of the new Republic she's
flanked by four other leaders including
one of the grand race and after we saw
her short haircut in Rogue one similar
to the cut she had in Return of the Jedi
she's back to a more senatorial hairdo
from Andor showing how she's back to
having to play that annoying political
game but the chamber behind them has the
same exact Amphitheater design as we saw
in the Rebel Alliance Fleet war room and
return the Jedi on to the next clip I
started hearing whispers
about Brown's return
heir to the Empire
Soka said she started here Whispers of
thrawn's return as heir to the Empire
and Bam a from behind shot of grand
Admiral thrawn the former Imperial just
Mastermind from Timothy zahn's Legends
novels from the early 90s in my opinion
the best expanded universe literature
from this era now the first installment
of the thrawn novel Trilogy is called
heir to the Empire thus the nod here and
I think it's really a meta declaration
by Dave filoni that he's going to
continue to do this mission of gradually
re-canonizing much of the best legend
storylines and characters and this
process really started with polony
bringing thrawn into Star Wars Rebels
where he was voiced by Mars Mickelson
and was the primary antagonist of that
series until he and Ezra Richard
disappeared in hyperspace with the Pergo
this guy is brilliant he was able to
deduce that Darth Vader was Anakin
Skywalker based solely on Vader's barrel
roll flight Maneuvers like Anakin did in
the Battle of course on at the beginning
of Revenge of the Sith this guy watches
the tape now on Saturday's panel at Star
Wars celebration it was confirmed that
Lawrence Mickelson will indeed play the
character after voicing him for Star
Wars Rebels which is really great
because he has the perfect boys and the
perfect face for the role and this saves
us a lot of time for having to CSI
analyze the shape of thrawn's ears here
where all the stars rock
wow so this gold trimmed Bridge of the
ship thrawn marches out on looks like it
is looking out over a hilly Seaside
terrain looking a lot like the planet
kalavala bocaton's home which was
recently bombed by Imperial forces in
the Mandalorian chapter 19. I theorize
thrawn could have been leading the fleet
behind that attack and he might now be
surveying that damage ahsoka's t16
approaches the new Republic ship and
Morgan ellsmith now stands on that same
golden bridge looking out on a starry
background with a planet's Stratosphere
below two ra7 protocol Droids on the far
sides are navigating the last time we
saw Morgan Elizabeth Soca demanded from
her now tell me
where is your master
where is Grand Admiral thrawn and we
have been waiting for this trailer in
this series ever since that moment three
years ago now Ahsoka in this section
seems to be in a red-leafed forest the
same city that Balin is standing in and
these dark trunks look a lot like the
previously burned down force that we saw
in corvus in Chapter 13 this could just
be what those trees look like when the
vegetation regrows let's move on
we have to prepare for the worst
the Jedi fell a long time ago
there aren't many left okay we're back
in the temple ruins with this projected
star map in the scene with Ahsoka and
Balin there are floodlights and
projector bulbs maybe Ahsoka has set up
a kind of Camp here to try to read the
star map to track down Ezra and thrawn
Balin doesn't want her to leave with
that knowledge why because it could
expose Palpatine in the city eternal's
path from biss to exigol like we could
be seeing the origins of that Sith
wayfinder that kylo Ren found at the
beginning of Rise of Skywalker to trace
his way to exigol they have announced
that we are getting one huge movie to
bridge all these Mandalorian era shows
like Ahsoka to the force awakens and
it's going to be directed by Dave filoni
and then after that chronologically
we're gonna get a Rey movie with Daisy
Ridley set 15 years after the rise of
Skywalker so it looks like they're gonna
be doing a lot of work to contextualize
and make a lot more sense of the sequel
Trilogy era as they duel I like how
Ahsoka ignites only one of her white
lightsaber blades remember she got these
from that lightsaber duel with the sixth
brother whom she dueled in the finale of
tales of the Jedi but rather than
igniting the second lightsaber at her
hip she kicks off the boulder to Lunge
at Bayland she uses her surroundings
there's a very quick shot of Harrison
Dola her new Republic patch is five red
dots meaning the rank of Admiral she
might have exceeded Admiral Akbar as
admiral of the new Republic Fleet or
Leia's resistance Fleet she got a shout
out in Rogue one as general cindula over
the intercom sounds like she's promoted
since then to Admiral makes total sense
she's flanked by a lieutenant and Amman
calamari blue Squadron pilot maybe one
of the ones who drink with Zeb and Teva
in that Adelphi Top Gun bar recently in
the Mandalorian the blue Squadron was
supposedly retired after the battle of
scarif in Rogue one but the ghost did
Cameo in that battle so presumably Hera
and Zeb were there for it and they could
be Legacy members of the blue Squadron
Shin chases down ahsoka's T6 and Balin
charges on some new Republic Soldiers
with his hood up making him look a lot
like Darth Vader in that kill box
sequence at the end of Rogue one down to
a vicious Force choke as Sabine sadly
looks at an image of Ezra Bridger played
by Iman espandi and on the walls of her
bunk are drawings a loath wolf and a few
loathe cats she really really misses her
boy from lothal moving on
[Music]
Ahsoka duel someone who I assume is an
Inquisitor he looks like the eighth
brother which would be weird to have
this late after the Empire's fall he has
that same dual wield ring grip blade
that the inquisitors use and spin the
blades around Ahsoka is able to repel
him with the force push from just two
fingers as she continues to hold the
hilt and ignite it a move that we saw
Keller and Beck use on clone troopers
while he saved grogu the Machinery being
taken apart looks like old Star
Destroyer engines in this industrial
setting could be part of the Imperial
Fleet decommissioning process that the
new Republic has been taking their sweet
ass time to do and the background on the
left that is clearly an Imperial Star
Destroyer with the outline of the
spherical Shield generator at the very
top of it Ahsoka leaps out of a control
room window at the setting shattering
the window that Waterfront background
makes it look like the same planet that
Hera and Chopper were flying the Phantom
over when they were trying to bring down
another ship that's Towing apart the
text calls Ahsoka Warrior Outcast Rebel
and lastly Jedi as if that is the last
of the modifiers she would use to
describe herself onto the final clip
time to begin
to begin
[Music]
foreign
the mark IV architect Droid who was
based aboard the Jedi ship The Crucible
his job was to teach younglings
including a young Mace Windu and young
Yoda on how to build their lightsabers
he took a young Ahsoka to illum to find
her first kyber crystal in this scene
he's probably telling Sabine and Ahsoka
that it's time to begin searching for
Ezra again but in a broader meta context
it feels like he's encouraging the
beginning of a new Jedi Order the one
that Rey will assemble in her future
film decades after this remember in that
mysterious Jedi forces moment in the
rise of Skywalker one of the past Jedi
was Ashley eckstein's voice as Ahsoka
Tano so I believe there is a link
between these two Jedi throughout
history let me know your favorite part
of this trailer and what you're most
looking forward to from Ahsoka reminded
to subscribe to our new channel the Deep
dive where I just did an intense
analysis of Christopher Nolan's
Interstellar you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at EA boss follow
And subscribe to new rockstars thanks
for watching bye
[Music]